- Hey guys, today's date
is March 24th, 2020.
I want you to know that
because all the information
I'm sharing makes sense
up until this date.
The situation is evolving rapidly,
so know that things do change.
That being said, one of my
main goals on this channel
is to beat up on misinformation.
And I've done a "Doctor Fact
Checks Media" video already.
You loved that.
Now I'm doing a "Doctor
Fact Checks Politicians"
because I've seen some
politicians make statements
that are at best, negligent,
and at times, purposefully inaccurate.
But before we start,
I wanna make a comment
about ending social distancing.
This week, the story has moved to how long
should we be doing the social distancing?
Is it worth the economic impact
of closing of small businesses,
people losing their jobs,
the stock market taking a tumble?
And it's actually a good question.
We should be asking it.
And doctors like myself should
really be providing answers
in a time of unknowns.
I just watched a panel on
FOX News of President Trump,
Vice President Pence, a few others,
talking about this exact issue.
President Trump made a statement
where he says, "We should
be getting back to work
"around April 12th," which is Easter time.
Now many people are asking,
"Is that the wise move to do?"
We don't know.
We don't know if that's
the right move to do yet.
We need to conduct more tests.
We need to get doctors on the front lines,
their equipment that we
need to treat patients,
and we need see what's happening,
how the situation is evolving.
Making any kind of
prediction now for April 12th
is a full-on guess.
We don't have all the numbers.
We don't know how the
situation's gonna evolve.
So I think we need to pump
the breaks a little bit.
At this very moment, the reason why I say
the economic losses are still worth it
because of the worry of run on hospitals.
This isn't a theoretical problem.
Italy's having it right now.
And if we have it here
in the United States,
people are gonna suffer,
not just those who are over
the age of 70.
Everyone's gonna pay a toll for this.
What I'd like to see happen
over the next few weeks,
hospitals get more prepared,
we transform civilian buildings
like Jacob Javits Center
right around the corner,
hotel rooms in order to
act as impromptu hospitals.
We get personal protective equipment
and ventilators to hospitals.
See how many people are sick
with proper testing kits.
And only once we have all this in place
in the next two weeks
can we then start talking about estimates.
Right now, no place for it.
During this Fox News White House panel,
they had three doctors on.
Dr. Sapphire, Dr. Siegel, and Dr. Oz,
each asking a question
of Vice President Pence
and President Trump.
Unfortunately, none of them
asked if our politicians
are afraid of a run on hospitals.
The simple question remains
what do we do and how do we
prepare for when millions
of people simultaneously
catch this novel coronavirus?
And even if 1% need ventilator support,
which is probably more than that,
how can we manage with
not enough equipment?
How do we manage with
not enough protection
where health providers are gonna get sick
and they have to stay home?
We need to think about
us on the front lines
and really get President Trump, Pence,
and everyone in the political sphere
to think about us and how we
need to manage the situation.
All right, let's fact
check some politicians
making statements about
the novel coronavirus
that may not be accurate,
and some that are really dangerous.
- The World Health Organization offered,
offered the testing kits
that they have available
and to give it to us now.
We refused them.
- Were testing kits available
that were perfectly fine?
Yes, however, these tests
are largely reserved
for low-income countries
that don't have the testing capacity,
don't have the ability
to make their own tests.
In fact, many countries
were making their own tests
and not taking them because
they have the economy
to do so.
How would it look if
an economic superpower
like the US started claiming
these kits for themselves?
Just pretty bad.
I think what really slowed
down our response time
was that the initial test
the CDC sent out were faulty.
And second, it took
forever to commercialize
these tests for private labs
to do this sort of testing.
Now that that's happening,
where BioReference, LabCorp
are able to do them,
we can get more tests done.
- We have a drug called chloroquine.
A derivation would be hydroxychloroquine.
We think it has very
serious, very good impact
on what we're talking about
with respect to the virus.
So you'll take a look at that,
then you can coordinate with us.
But I think to me, that's a game changer.
First and foremost, it's
not a game changer yet, yet.
We like to be optimistic
in the medical community,
but first and foremost, we
have to be healthy skeptics.
That does not mean we
disbelieve everything we hear.
It means that we have to take everything
with a grain of salt,
especially basing it on limited research.
The research that we have presented
thus far is mainly anecdotal research,
meaning stories or
certain compassionate uses
where we're just using that medication
in an experimental form.
In fact, there was a recent research study
that came out combining
hydroxychloroquine,
this anti-malaria
medication with azithromycin
which is an antibiotic medication.
And it found that it decreased
the amount of the virus
that's present in the nasopharyngeal swabs
that we use to test for it.
Now this is a very small study.
It wasn't randomized.
The people that got both
drugs were only six.
That's a very small number.
So until we do a proper clinical trial,
and understand exactly what it means
to have less virus in your nose,
because what good is it
if you have less virus
in your nose, but you're still
showing horrible symptoms
and still having the same outcomes?
We need more info, that's what I'm saying.
We need to do more research
before we start calling
it a miracle drug, a game changer.
Because what happens?
People start taking it unnecessarily
and get side effects.
All medications have side effects.
In fact, there was a
couple that ended up taking
some kind of form of chloroquine,
I think it was to clean
their aquarium or fish tank
and ended up dying.
Well, the husband died and now the wife
is in an intensive care unit.
So we need to be very careful
with our language here.
Another issue that I'm sure the President
didn't think about when
he made these statements,
now it's nearly impossible for my patients
who have been taking hydroxychloroquine,
brand name Plaquenil, for
lupus or different types
of autoimmune conditions to get it
because of this rush on pharmacies
because people think it cures
or treats the novel coronavirus.
I think at a time like this,
we have to look to the major organizations
to give us guidance.
Dr. Fauci cleared up some
of the fact checking there.
The FDA came out and said
they have not FDA approved
hydroxychloroquine to be a treatment.
Are we using it some
compassionate use cases?
Yes, but we have to understand
this is experimental use
only at this time.
- This disease could take your life,
but that's not the scariest thing to you.
There's something that
would be worse than dying.
- Yeah.
And look, I'm gonna do
everything I can to live,
but you know, if you said,
"Are you willing to take a chance?"
You know, and if I get sick,
I'll go and try to get better,
but if I don't, I don't.
And I'm not trying to think
in any kind of morbid way, Tucker.
But I'm just saying that
we got a choice here.
And we're gonna be in a total collapse,
recession, depression,
collapse on our society
if this goes on another several months.
There won't be any jobs to
come back to for many people.
- The entire interview
sets up a false dichotomy.
We're okay, putting at risk
those above the age of 70,
or we have the economic
collapse of this country.
This is a purely false dichotomy.
It's not that simple.
There are many choices to be made.
And it's not about saying this
is gonna take nine months,
or six months, or three
months, or two weeks
because we don't know.
It's an evolving situation
that we constantly have to monitor
and make changes when appropriate.
Now the reason I bring
up the false dichotomy
is because we need to understand
that it's not just about those
over the age of 70.
If we open the country back up too early,
the risk isn't just to them.
It's to all of us.
Not only are 30-year-olds,
20-year-olds, 50-year-olds
still gonna get sick,
some of them severely,
there's still a death
rate in those people,
but it's gonna happen so quickly
that hospitals like my own,
like the ones in New York City
are gonna get overrun,
and doctor are not gonna
be able to provide care,
not only to coronavirus
patients, but to everyone.
You're gonna be a 20-year-old
involved in a car accident.
Those happen all the time.
Guess what?
ICU's full of corona patients.
Where are you gonna go?
If you're diagnosed with cancer
and you need an infusion,
we don't have anymore IV
supplies because we're using them
on the coronavirus patients.
Where are you gonna go?
This is not just about those
who are over the age of 70.
I encourage Lieutenant Governor
to come to New York City,
take a look at the hospitals.
They're already, here, overcrowded.
The ICUs are nearly working at capacity.
We're going through 40 to
70,000 N95 masks a day,
and that's with the economy shutdown.
Imagine we open it up
and everybody gets sick at the same time.
Who's gonna take care of these people?
I have no idea.
Because I'll tell you exactly
what happens if we do that,
we're gonna run out of
equipment, first and foremost.
Doctors are gonna be facing
decisions on who intubate.
The 20-year-old who has
no medical problems?
The 30-year-old who has two kids?
The 50-year-old who has
a family, but smokes,
or the 70-year-old who
has many health problems,
but has been paying into
Social Security and Medicare
their entire lives.
How do you make that decision?
Healthcare providers
are still gonna be there
on the front lines
'cause that's what we do.
We're gonna get sick.
We're gonna start losing our lives.
We're gonna start showing up to work.
And who's gonna be there to
take care of the patients
who need help that are
not coronavirus patients?
I don't have an answer to that.
So it's not as simple as,
"Let's open up the country
"to save jobs."
We all want that.
We don't want the economy
to collapse as doctors.
In fact, something Trump said earlier
on another press conference is,
"If doctors just had their way,
"they'd shut down the entire country
"for a period of time."
Yeah, maybe in an experiment form,
but not in real life.
We don't wanna destroy the economy.
We wanna make sure that we lose
the least amount of lives possible,
we keep hospitals up and running,
and we're able to take
care of as many people
while maintaining a proper economy.
Now can we open up the
country in a few weeks time?
It's very possible.
But we need to wait.
We need to get more testing kits done.
We need to get providers the protection
we need on the front lines,
and then make evaluations as they come.
There's no need to go
on national television
and say something dramatic,
that you're willing to lay down your life
for the novel coronavirus
to save the economy.
'Cause it's a false dichotomy
and an inaccurate statement.
- He's defunded Centers
for Disease Control.
- They've cut the funding for the CDC.
- The reality of the matter
is that neither of these
statements are true.
In 2019, Trump proposed a cut
of $1.36 billion to the CDC.
He proposed this cut.
Congress wouldn't let him have.
Instead, they increased the
CDC budget by $261.6 million.
For 2020, Trump proposed cutting
the CDC budget by $750 million, bad idea.
Congress wouldn't let him do it.
Instead, they signed
a 420 million increase
to the CDC budget.
So while yes, Trump has
proposed cuts to the CDC,
he's tried cutting their budget.
He's never tried to fully defund it,
and he's never successfully
cut the budget.
In fact, over the last two years,
that budget has gone up.
Please, politicians, when you're making
statements like this, tell the full story.
- [Bryant] The nasal passages,
and the nasal membranes are
the coolest part of the body.
That's why the virus tends to go there
until it then becomes healthy
enough to go into the lungs.
This sounds really goofy
and it did to me too,
but it works.
Once the the temperature
reaches 136 degrees fahrenheit,
the virus falls apart and
just disintegrates, okay?
And I said, "Well, how would
you get the temperature
"up to 132 degrees?"
The answer was, "You use a blow dryer,"
because it's capable of doing that.
So you hold a blow dryer
in front of your face
and you inhale with your nose,
and it kills all the viruses in your nose.
- This is the prime
example of misinformation,
where it sounds like
something's totally feasible
and reasonable to do to protect yourself
from the novel coronavirus
that has zero scientific backing,
and it has 100% potential to harm you.
So if you're gonna have a blow dryer,
first of all, most blow
dryers, I just looked this up,
don't get nearly as hot
as 140 degrees fahrenheit.
They get somewhere around 110, 120.
Some of the higher end ones can.
But even if they do,
they're gonna burn you!
What this county council
member is suggesting
is that we blow dry our noses
which will, A, dry up our
nasal mucus membranes,
making us more susceptible to a virus
by causing cracks in the skin.
Two, it's gonna burn our faces.
Especially if we're doing
this in the elderly population
that have more sensitive skin.
So no, 140 degrees directly to the face
will cause first-degree burns.
Please do not do this.
Just to update you on
the N95 mask situation.
In my last video, I donate
$27,000 worth of masks.
It was a tough time as
you probably have seen.
People have reached out.
And some people have been
trying to make a dollar on me
by selling me more masks.
Not doing that anymore.
But then there's many of you
that have offered donations
and I wanna thank you for those who have.
One of the biggest donations thus far
has been coppercompression.com
they donated 18,000 reusable KN95 masks.
These are gonna make a
world of a difference
to us on the front lines.
Huge thank you to them.
I'm dropping their link down below.
Check out their other products
that are copper infused.
I put together a playlist for you
of some of my favorite videos here.
And if you haven't seen
me haggle and negotiate
for life-saving equipment
for the tune of $50,000,
click here while staying
happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)